foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
together
oh
man you'd rather be so cold
are you ready yeah
[Music]
good mind
s
[Music]
hey Christian yeah
right again
I'm ready
Quinn getting the shot
just modeling
so freaking beautiful I wish I had a
polarizer so you can see how blue the
water is
but it's
so clear
the mountains
so beautiful this morning
ah it's hard to film and paddle at the
same time I will say I'm not sure I can
do it stuff will go overboard including
myself so I'm just gonna float while we
filmed
[Music]
you know they said
I had my first breakdown
[Music]
[Applause]
you are
cleaned it up
my way
that gives us a little more purpose too
make it a little harder than it is
so pretty up here
foreign
Lake Tahoe for Idaho
I didn't know I'd be back to the Eastern
Sierra again so soon
but under very different circumstances
this trip to the Sawtooth Mountains and
the Tetons would be the very last trip
with my home as I've always known it
deep down I knew something wasn't right
because well there were signs
but I was reluctant to peel away the
layers and see what was really going on
because you know ignorance is bliss
it was easier to tell myself I was
worrying for nothing and to keep the
adventure going
so
that's what I did
[Music]
foreign
thank you
I'll gravitate towards his life I'm
still thinking or BTS or anything that's
like educational related that's
essentially what I'm filming most of the
time is a lot of b-roll stuff and then
trying to piece it all together and tell
a story well that sounds amazing I would
love to work with you guys
but eventually the signs were yelling at
me
the van smelled musty it felt damp and I
could see that water was consistently
pooling under the edge of my flooring
something was very wrong
okay
I have an issue where water is leaking
out of this corner and pooling
and it's been going on for a little bit
and this sub more is soaked I've lifted
this up and looked back there with a
headlamp and it doesn't appear to be
soaked much further back
but I just don't know where this is
coming from like what the heck
so I began by first checking the pump
the plumbing lines and then the space
beneath the fridge
and what I found was
nothing
absolutely no sign of elite
okay what a journey the last few days
has been I haven't actually been
documenting it really because it's just
been a lot to take in but I
ripped up my floor
um I was noticing a really like musty
wet mildewy smell
and so I ripped up one floorboard
and uh yeah my fears were confirmed the
subfloor underneath was absolutely
soaked and it was slimy so I pulled up
the next floor board same thing pulled
up the next one and there was a baseball
size patch of mold
so that was game over I like started
ripping literally everything up I just
decided to start ripping flooring up
because I was smelling some really
concerning smells and
yeah that's definitely mold
pretty bad guys I don't know what to do
except for continue ripping it out just
keeps getting worse
further back I go
luckily this house that I'm staying at
they're so cool the guy Steve was like
oh my gosh use my tools like he came out
to help me to show me how everything
worked and I just started hacking away
at the van
and it's a really good thing I did
because the subfloor almost all the way
to the back was just soaked
all of the wood
just
soaked I have no idea what's causing it
it's not coming from the door because it
goes all the way back
foreign
so much water
luckily I didn't see any more patches of
mold but it smelled like it was
beginning to get there
um so yeah I've been ripping everything
up and sawing around these cabinets and
everything but the cabinets are going to
have to come out because it is wet going
underneath like the subfloor down here
still wet my van is like a disaster it's
a freaking construction zone I've been
tearing my whole house apart
the good news is I've been able to
pinpoint what the issue is and it's the
plumbing so at first I was like oh crap
like when I replaced the pump I did it
wrong
but that's not the case I've been
troubleshooting it by running the water
without it going down the drain and also
running it with it going down the drain
when water goes down the drain it then
seeps out
here
like a lot a lot of water seeps out and
that's what was causing everything to
get waterlogged so I now have no floor
apart from what's underneath the
cabinets and um
I'm gonna have to plan to like rebuild
everything but I'm trying to at least
fix the plumbing problem so that the the
leak stops and I ordered some rugs to
put down
just as a Band-Aid until I can get
somewhere and actually
do a rebuild
yeah that's been life lately
it's really bad
Spirits out